the world is as delicate and as
complicated as a spider's web and like a
spider's web if you touch one thread you
send shutters running through all the
other threads that make up the web but
we're not just touching the web we're
tearing great holes in
it the unique ecosystem we have on this
planet is an incredibly complex web of
species and there is no one species in
it that is unimportant so the removal of
any species from our ecosystem can have
devastating impact but species aren't
going extinct at a rate of one or two a
year it's difficult to estimate but
anywhere between 200 and 100,000 species
go extinct every single year most of
them unnown to science and the impact we
are having on our planet the damage we
are doing to our ecosystem will soon
start to have severe consequences for us
as a species not just in terms of the
resources that we have available to us
but do we really want to live in a world
where current biodiversity is just a
memory my answer to that question is no
and that's why I'm supporting durl in
this year's project for awesome durl is
an international conservation charity
whose mission statement is to prevent
species from going extinct and they
often focus on what they call Little
Brown jobs these aren't headline
grabbing species like whales or pandas
but they are incredibly important
species for their ecosystems durl was
named after Gerald durl who was a legend
AR naturalist and reluctant author who
changed the face of conservation by his
radical idea of using Zoological Gardens
as breeding centers for endangered
species now you might have heard of him
through some of his books like the
stationary Arc or my family and other
animals but his legacy lives on in what
durl the organization now does durl
strategy of preventing species from
going extinct has three components
firstly they run programs in the field
across the world secondly they have
their main site on the island of Jersey
in the Channel Islands which they use as
a breeding center for endangered species
and also also as a visitor center
thirdly they own a conservation Academy
educating conservationists from all over
the world to a postgraduate level I
believe that the work that durl does is
some of the most important done by any
charity in the world today not just in
terms of preserving biodiversity for the
sake of doing so but also to preserve
the continued existence and success of
our own species darl Works in 14
countries all over the world in their
field programs and they've realized that
the key to any success any long-term
success of conservation strategy is
engaging with local communities for
example in Madagascar Daryl has worked
with the creation of over 170
community-led organizations which manage
natural resources and protect
biodiversity from threats including
habitat destruction which is exactly
what they're doing with species like the
alatan gental Lima and the plowshare
toras possibly my favorite though is the
orangutang project which is run in the
field in Sumatra but also has a breeding
center on the island of Jersey now on
Jersey there's been a thriving
population of rut tangs for the past
four decades and they've had seven
babies born in that time which have been
sent all over the world to boost
populations of this critically
endangered species now the footage you
just saw was shot when I went to the
site on Jersey and it's literally my
favorite place in the whole world I I
love the durl park the whole reason that
it exists is so that they can build up
secure populations of critically
endangered species under really
carefully managed conservation
conditions and this is such that if the
worst happens and a species go extinct
in the wild then we have a safety net
population which if the conditions allow
can be reintroduced into the wild for
some species that reintroduction can
happen right now as has been happening
with tamarinds now these are little
primates from Brazil which have been
critically endangered for some time and
Daryl has been really successful in
breeding them and reintroducing them
into the wild and trying to boost
genetic stocks also on the site on darl
is the internationally acclaimed
conservation Academy which is like a
mini University of conservationists and
they've trained over 3 a half thousand
people from all over the world from over
150 countries and they don't just give
them technical information
like uh an education and genetics they
train them to go back to their countries
and to take the lead on conservation
projects to go out into the field and to
share their wisdom and to create
projects of their own and they've been
so successful in doing that darl has
100% saved species from Extinction for
example two species the maian Castel at
one point there are only four
individuals left in the world darl work
with species intensively and now there
are over 350 another key species that
they've worked with is the Rodriguez
fruit P which are is an absolutely
adorable little mammal and uh when they
first worked with it there were 350 left
in the world and now the population is
over 10,000 so D is currently working
with over 50 species and a sample of 17
of those have their Extinction risk
percentage graphed over time and you can
see that durl is having a definitely
quantifiable impact a paper released in
2010 indicated that since the 1980s 63
species of mammals amphibians and birds
have been moved up the red list of uh
extin iction risk solely due to the work
of conservationists and durl represents
10% of those efforts one charity
represents 10% of the global response to
a global problem this is what makes darl
so remarkable for me it's a small
charity with a global reach it just
needs more funds to do more of the same
work more broadly so that's why I'm
imploring you to support it in the
project for awesome now in addition to
voting for this video and trying to get
some funding for the charity you can
also contribute directly if you go to
www.d.org you can check out the website
they have information on all the animals
they work with on all their conservation
programs on everything they do and I
recommend you do because it's it's
incredible work and if You' like the
look at what you see then you can
support them you can become a member and
donate regularly you can adopt an animal
or you can just make a one-off donation
and if you live nearby I'd highly
recommend you go to the darl wildlife
park because there's really nothing like
it I think the work that darl does is so
important because I don't want to have
to live in a world where in years to
come I have to tell my grandchildren
that well I ran around forests that were
full of life and I got to play in ponds
with toads and frogs and I saw the sky
full of
suns they don't get to see that because
I saw a problem I didn't do anything
about it because globally we knew what
was happening and we did
nothing I do not want to have to say
that to my
grandchildren this is one of the most
important issues in the world today and
it is not getting enough attention and
it is certainly not getting enough
funding so
please please do support the work that
darl is doing whether that's in the
project for awesome or more broadly my
hopes for the work that durl does
summarized pretty neatly in a message
that was left in a time capsule on the
site in Jersey by Gerald darl himself I
I think I should just read that to
you we hope that there will be fireflies
and gloworms at night to guide you and
butterflies and hedges and forests to
greet you we hope that your Dawns will
have an orchestra of bird song and that
the sound of their wings and the
opalescence of their coloring will
Dazzle you we hope that there will still
be the extraordinary varieties of
creatures sharing the land of the planet
with you to enchant you and enrich your
lives as they have done for us we hope
that you will be grateful for having
been born into such a magical
world